15 out of every 100 people in the uk
have a disability but just 4 in 100 have
a blue badge it's the scheme that allows
you to park on yellow lines and in
parking places for as long as you need
it
and if you just step back
okay and round
and let's tuck me up nice and toasty but
disability campaigners say some city
centers are squeezing them out
in york there are new security barriers
keeping out all vehicles from a larger
area of the city center
i think the fact that there are so many
people
it sparked protests from blue badge
holders who've lost access to more shops
and services
many of us can't walk
very far down that street or
for example today i have a wheelchair i
have my carer but i don't always have
that and if i want to go out with
friends i
need to be able to park so close that i
can walk the 10 metres that i can walk
to go to the place i'm going to
[Music]
christmas markets have drawn crowds at
the end of another challenging year for
shoppers and traders
but campaigners say some councils across
the country have reduced disabled
parking during the pandemic
and fear york's permanent changes could
be copied elsewhere
almost like an apartheid situation i do
think it's that serious and i think
other towns and cities will actually
look at how to keep their city centres
more car free
but disabled people need to be at the
table when those discussions are
happening
york city council says it needs the new
restrictions to keep people safe from
potential terror attacks and that it
acted on clear police advice it's
pledged to improve facilities for the
less mobile and appoint an access
officer the protesters are not convinced
york's lack of access could yet end up
in court campaigners have crowdfunded
more than 5 000 pounds and hope to
challenge the council under the equality
act
they see the new barriers as simple
discrimination
in the meantime they remain closed from
10 30 every morning gerard sky news york